many children in the world might we'll
take an activity like this for granted
but for these two brothers it's a dream
come true they are easy DS and they
escaped from Islamic state last week for
seven months thirteen-year-old side was
forced to train to become a future
fighter and it was brutal lot of fun
they showed us beheading videos and said
this is how you hold the head here in
cottage side was featured prominently in
an is propaganda video shot at the
group's major training site for children
known as Farooq Academy for cubs
training went on for nine hours a day
and included military drills and
ideological indoctrination what will
occur they told us your religion is bad
it's for infidels is llamas good gotcha
sighs mother still vividly remember the
day ious militants took side away but it
was good I cried and begged them not to
take him I didn't want them to take away
his brother too so I hit him was veena
jameel and his mother had no idea what
happened to side Jamil was forced to
work at the office of a localized chief
or a mere in a town in northern Syria
monday the Emir came and showed us a
video clip and said do you know any of
these boys my mother said this one is my
son it would the same propaganda video
moved by side mother's pleadings the
Emir used his authority to reunite side
with his family a month later the three
ran away with the help of an underground
network that rescues Yazidis kidnapped
by ious site says he still can't believe
he's free he had come up with some
disparate ideas on how to escape nah
what up god I told myself that if they
send me to fight one day I will open
fire and I ass fighters and run away
gotcha sighs as he tries not to think
about the past and keeps himself busy
with family and friends his biggest wish
is to see his father too bro
others and sister again they were taken
away by eyes last year